hot breath yeah i think it's important
you take it to the next level where
you'll write it but then
actually say it with which then you
almost have to start justifying your
words and i find a lot of editing when i
say things out loud and you
do you almost find the
the big punch line once you start saying
it out loud
is that when you really start to bring
it to life
uh it's almost like you have the the
points
but it's like connecting the dots it's
like
you have the feel the points out there
and it's like
it's like connecting them you know i
mean i think a funny way to connect them
you know or or you know or concept
like getting a concept down and like
playing with the concept until you come
up with the jokes
there's different ways i guess there's
two different ways of doing it
finding that finding the finding the
points first and then finding your way
to the points
versus creating a concept and finding
finding
the points afterwards and you i don't
know if that makes sense
that makes sense to me in my head but
maybe i'm not explaining it
i'm not explaining it very well i don't
think but it's just
the way my mind works it's like you know
those are two ways of doing it coming up
with a concept and then
finding the points locating the points
and then the concept to get into those
points